bonsoir enjambera merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france on a entendu
vos collègues élus parisiens notamment
vivent des situations un petit peu
rocambolesque aujourd'hui je crois
savoir que ça a été un petit peu notre
cas aussi à l'ail et les roses
manifestement ce que vous entendez
parler y ait eu un petit souci début de
votre réponse oui est ce que vous nous
entendez voilà alors je me sentais très
bien mon intervention cafouille un peu
comme c'est le cas pour cette campagne
vaccinale qui démarre effectivement
manière bien étrange puisque on se rend
compte que tout a été improvisée il ya
quinze jours de cela le gouvernement
disait on n'a pas besoin des mers pas
besoin des collectivités locales il
balayait d'un revers de main les
propositions dead
elle comprit des régions notamment dans
la région ile de france et puis lundi
dernier coup de téléphone on nous dit à
en a besoin de vous à ce que vous
acceptez d'être des partenaires de
l'état
mais évidemment on dit oui parce qu'on
veut protéger nos populations et être
les plus réactifs mais on s'attendait
des partenaires c'est à dire que chacun
fasse un bout du chemin
un bouquet chose or force est de
constater qu'en réalité on gère tout de
a à z de l'inscription qui est chaotique
en passant par la mobilisation des
médecins et des soignants en passant par
l'organisation de toute la logistique en
inde en étendant la commande des
seringue des cotons et jusqu'à là et
c'est l'anecdote du jour aller chercher
nous mêmes les vaccins la kia même pas
de service de livraison des vaccins
j'étais moi même en tant que maire dans
la petite zoé sur les routes ce matin
pour aller à l'hôpital sainte-anne
récupérer mes 25 petites doses de vaccin
on voit bien qu'il ya un vrai sujet à
une vraie improvisation c'est ça
pourrait prêter à rire s'il n'y avait
pas des vies derrière et des enjeux
considérables notamment la possibilité
pour notre pays de se sortir enfin de
cette crise de redémarrer et de
retrouver un semblant de vie normale et
une économie florissante à nouveau alors
question peut-être naïve mais
vous êtes allé chercher ses vaccins
qu'on doit conserver à moins 80 degrés
je crois dans votre voiture personnelle
mais c'est en fait les vaccins une fois
décongelés ont une durée de vie de cinq
jours donc en réalité on nous a remis
des doses décongeler qu'il faut
conserver entre 4 et 8 degrés c'est à
dire au frigo dans un swing aux normales
par contre on a donc cinq jours
uniquement
et une fois que la petite fiole est
ouverte on a globalement six heures pour
injecter le vaccin
donc oui on peut aller avec un véhicule
normal a effectivement nous on était
venu plein d'espoir avec deux belles
grosses glaciaire en disant on va
revenir avec plein de vaccins pour
vacciner notre population et la vérité
c'est globalement on m'a remis une
petite boîte de chocolats deux petites
25 toute petite dose donc c'est vrai que
tous avaient à l'aller un semblant un
peu ridicule donc on est heureux d'avoir
pu commencer les vaccinations
aujourd'hui mais alors que en une seule
journée vendredi dernier j'ai eu quatre
mille inscriptions
globalement on a réussi à faire 25
piqûre aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
commencé à 13 heures et avec le peu de
doses que nous avons on en aura à peine
une cinquantaine demain vous voyez 4000
inscrits 5 quand doses par jour
il ya quelque chose qui va pas vers ce
genre bras est ce que vous vous
expliquer où l'on vous expliquer
pourquoi vous avez été aussi peu livrés
non je ne le comprends pas parce qu'il
ya une incohérence entre le chiffre
qu'on nous annonce à l'échelle globale à
l'échelle des régions et ce qu'on voit
réellement sur le terrain
et l'explication qu'on est en train de
se donner et j'ai entendu à travers des
interventions de certains représentants
de la majorité qui était sur les
plateaux télé envoyé un peu en mission
kamikaze de ce week end mais ils ont
commencé à nous expliquer qu'en fait on
gérer la pénurie en bon père de famille
parce que on voulait être sûre de ne
jamais manquer de vaccins
donc c'est très drôle parce que moi j'ai
la conviction qu'au contraire on ferait
vacciner 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
pour essayer de vacciner leur population
le plus vite possible et à côté de ça on
a un ministre de la santé qui ne vous
inquiétez pas on théorise on met de côté
en stock pour être sûr de jane eyre
manqué mais en fait de fait on en manque
sur le terrain et c'est assez terrible
et on peut imaginer qu'ils en stock
parce qu'ils ne sont pas certains de la
filière d'approvisionnement et que comme
vous le savez ce vaccin nécessite deux
ans deux injections et que en gros pour
chaque injection fait là dans ces quatre
premières semaines ils stockent
l'équivalent pour qu'on puisse continuer
à faire la deuxième injection
ça peut être logique si effectivement
ils ont des craintes mais ça veut dire
qu'ils devraient le dire à la population
doit être transparent dix ans on pense
qu'on sera pas libéré de tout ce qu'on
appelle justement vous êtes sur la même
ligne que la maire de lille martine
aubry qui a réagi vivement ce matin en
l'écoutant nous pouvons faire beaucoup
plus à condition d'avoir les vaccins je
suis inquiète que le gouvernement dise
la vérité sur le nombre de vaccins
disponibles
vincent genvrin vous avez aussi le
sentiment l'instar de martine aubry on
nous dit pas toute la vérité vous l'a
réclamé au gouvernement aujourd'hui
absolument moi je les accuse pas dire
vérité je pense que ne nous disent pas
les problèmes qu'ils rencontrent
notamment le fait qu'ils ont ont démarré
tout ça trop tard
on a reçu nos vaccins en france en même
temps que tous les autres pays européens
la livraison s'est effectuée le même
jour par tout simplement voit bien que
les autres pays ont démarré au quart de
tour et que nous on est à la traîne
donc on a envie déjà de les entendre et
moi j'aurais envie d'entendre un mea
culpa
oui on a mal géré et oui on démarre mal
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
appelé les maires à la rescousse en
catastrophe et qu'on leur demande de
tout gérer de a à z
moi je vous le dis très clairement
j'aurais passé comment directement au
laboratoire c'était pareil il n'y a pas
une aide supplémentaire qui est
intervenu pour aider la collectivité à
mettre les choses en place
donc il ya cette première problématique
de on n'a pas des aides on est on a
démarré en retard
et puis derrière on voudrait avoir la
vérité sur le calendrier parce que quand
on nous dit ne vous inquiétez pas il y
aura un million de vaccinés en fin
janvier
imaginons mais la vérité sexy janvier
c'est à dire qu'on aura que 1 million
fin février puisque avec ce système de
deux injections pour être vraiment
vacciner ça veut dire que concrètement
il va falloir refaire passer tous ceux
qui ont été vaccinés une première fois
donc on bloque toute la filière et pour
vous dire les choses simplement à l'haÿ
les roses c'est comme pour
tine aubry on était dimensionnée pour
200 injections par jour
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
on va au mieux réussir en faire une
cinquantaine on va voyez bien que déjà
il ya un premier aka et deuxièmement
quand bien même j'aurais réussi à
vacciner 200 personnes par jour au bout
de quatre semaines
eh bien il faut s'arrêter et reprendre
au début ça veut dire que effectivement
en fait on va paralyser le système si on
n'a pas de nouvelles doses à chaque fois
qu'on interpelle le gouvernement
à chaque fois qu'on interpelle les
services de l'état il nous confirme que
pour l'instant ils n'ont pas plus de 2
merci beaucoup en tout cas vincent
genvrin nous avoir apporté votre
expérience précieuse de terrain merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france à